Welcome to to the workshop. Uh I am
Jonas. Um and this is Misha. We both
work at it.
>> Hi.
>> And the um this is going to be uh chaos.
I think pure chaos first of all because
we only we only decided uh last Monday
to do this and then there was like um
bunch of personal stuff and halftterm
and the kids were sick and then this
morning we came here and I thought this
was going to be like a like hour and 20
hackathon or something like that and
then we came here and we're told you're
going to do it without an audience
because of some fire thing. Uh and now
there's an audience again which is
amazing. So, we're going to do uh gonna
try and do this as like a improvised
hackathon, but I've only just pushed the
SDK literally one minute ago, and Misha
is going to try and sort of like live
fix it. But I I hope it'll still be
worth your time because I think there's
sort of some uh hopefully at least some
interesting ideas or or maybe like one
way to put it is I would like to find
out whether this is like dumb or cool.
Uh and and the um and you can help me
with that. So please also just like ask
clarifying questions because part of
this the reason we said last week okay
let's do this workshop is because these
have been ideas that have been kind of
noodling around over the last year but
we haven't really actually done anything
with it's not really like a commercial
value to it necessarily but I think um
it's it's basically how I would like to
build agent harnesses. So, you know,
I've been noodling with this uh uh for a
while now and and you know, obviously
you've got like Claude and you've got Pi
now, but back in the day you didn't. And
so, you make your own coding harness and
there's all these different ways to do
it. And I think um the way I would like
to do it is I would like to do it purely
event sourced. Um and I say here aka
debugable and that is because everything
kind of skirts around of being event
source like all these things without
quite being event sourced. There's
always something that has a side effect
that you later can't tell and then you
can only see it in the hotel traces or
something which doesn't really make
sense to me because normally these these
these agents the way they work and we'll
see that in a second is they already
have a log of events, right? So you so
if you just say everything that could
possibly happen is in there. It'll be
really easy to debug. Um and as we'll
see hopefully a little bit strange but
potentially in other ways also really
easy to to extend. Um, and then the
second thing is I want I want this to be
extensible and and we've seen this I
think with PI which is was just
incredible um how valuable it is to make
an agent extensible not just by humans
but also extensible by itself. Um and um
one thing that I want in the
extensibility is is I want I want it to
be composable. like I don't think we'll
get there within one hour with all of
you but but maybe afterwards if you say
oh this is actually cool and not dumb
we'll keep working on this and you can
say oh I made this extension you made
that extension and you can combine them
and um um because I think we don't
really yet know what is the best recipe
for for for agents basically for agent
harnesses and it's been too hard to
experiment even in pi like everything
has to run in a single thread in in in
in like one process over here on this
particular computer and so on and so
forth so I think I think we we can maybe
do a little bit better than that. Uh
then I think it should be on the edge
publicly rootable. Um
like the way I think of it is basically
an intelligent entity like a digital one
that's not a robot in the future. It's
just internet connected uh basically
server program, right? Like it just
speaks HTTP. So the slice broadly
speaking that should be sufficient for
almost anything. And then I would just
put these agents on the edge speaking to
the internet straight away. H this is
not very safe. None of what we're doing
today is safe by the way. There's no
authentication you'll see. you'll all be
able to see everybody else's event
streams and agents and and whatever
else. You should not put any secrets in
the actual payloads of the events or
rotate them afterwards, right? So, we
can um you know those things can be
solved, but broadly speaking, the moment
an agent exists, it should have a URL.
That's just like uh that's just my
opinion because otherwise like you end
up making all these things and then you
tie yourself backwards inventing a
connector concept just so you can get
Slack messages in or or god knows what.
And that I think that should be really
easy. um or like maybe like a human
should fill in a web form and the result
of the web form should be input for the
agent again or or something like that.
That's kind of like the same thing as as
a Slack web hook. And then it should be
distributed. And this is potentially uh
like a very double-edged sword as we'll
see like right but but by distributed I
mean you should be able to have uh an
agent um running uh sort of on one
computer here on a server and my my
plug-in running over here and your
plug-in running over there and yours is
written in Rust and mine is written in
in in Typescript and it all just doesn't
really matter. Um and um the reason that
is bad is because you will eventually
get race conditions and loops, right?
Like sort of like two plugins kind of
sending messages back and forth creating
like an endless stream of events in your
agent. Um but on the flip side, uh you
have those issues normally anyway in in
in most agent harnesses I've seen. So
it's quite good if you if you can kind
of preempt that a little bit. Okay. So
let's um let's talk about this uh thing
that we have invented for um oh my gosh
um why is this this isn't the same as in
my file system. So I'll use the one in
my file system. Um basically uh we have
created this this uh service over last
week called events.iterate.com.
It has a web UI um and uh we can um uh
we you can use that. I think you'll
certainly use it, but for now we'll just
play with it with curl because I think
it's it makes it in some sense more more
uh tractable. Um in the in the agents um
in the events uh app we have this
concept of agent paths. So just like a
file in a file system every agent has a
path as a hierarchy and you just have
here show this here you just have raw
events. This is YAML formatted raw
events in each of these paths. And that
is basically the the the entire uh the
entire primitive that we're going to be
building our agent on. And so we can
start by playing with this. We can say,
okay, we we have a path prefix. If you
copy this from the repo that Misha's
going to put it in the read me in a
second.
>> I'll I'll add workshop. MD as well.
>> Yeah. Uh yeah. Okay. Uh oh yeah, maybe
that's why. Um
>> I I added the readme but not the
workshop.
>> Yeah. So uh basically um let's set
ourselves a path prefix here. In my
case, that is just going to be uh Jonas
Templestein or something. Um they start
with forward slash by the way, which is
a little bit um awkward potentially. Uh
but the but the service is very tolerant
of you URL encoding your slashes or
doing whatever you want. But I want I I
wanted good curl economics. Uh but I
also wanted them to start with a forward
slash so you have like a well-
definfined route. Then for the base,
>> it is now pushed to the repo. But have
you have you shared the repo?
>> Oh yeah, because now you could actually
do this on your computer. Uh let's do
that actually. If you go to um
github.comiterate
there is an an ai-engineer-workshop
um
uh
and in there you should be able to if
you click on this workshop.nd file
that's what we're now going through. So
you should be able to copy and paste the
curls from there and again there's no
authentication so you can just do this
in uh in in fact why why don't a couple
>> are hitting our live deployments.
Okay. So,
>> uh like this is entirely just sort of
like a proof of concept of um
>> uh how I think this should work. Um
>> we're basically what we're going to do
is we're going to turn this simple event
stream into a fullyfledged agent without
like really deploying any server
software uh or or anything like that. Um
maybe uh yeah, I should be able to see
if anybody if anybody has managed to do
it. I'll wait until two or three people
have managed to successfully curl
something. Um, and then I'll carry on
because I think it'll be it'll be good
if you if you if you curl uh it
yourself. So, it's here in this AI
engineer workshop workshop.mmd.
>> If two people have the same name,
>> that's going to cause username, so
>> it doesn't matter. Um, that's fine.
>> Uh,
okay. There we go. Got a few people. Um,
okay. So, that's pretty good. Um,
by the way, uh, you might see this here
and there. There's also this thing down
here called project slug. If you really
start stepping on each other's toes, you
can just type what like use a different
project slack and it's like a completely
new database, a new namespace. Um, you
can pass that in as an HTTP header. If
anybody needs that later, you can you
can ask me. Uh, okay. So now we have a
few people curling things. I will also
for start curling things. So, uh, now
I'm just going to say hello world, uh,
here to my stream
and it'll come back and and and we
straight away we notice like a few
things. There's a basic event envelope
shape. We have a type that I've just
invented here. Events don't need to have
anything but a type, but most of them
also have a payload. Uh, then um the uh
there is the stream path which came from
the URL that we posted this to. And
there's an offset. This is just an auto
incrementing integer that starts at one.
Uh and so there's basically like a point
of serialization at the server that just
increments them and you get a created
created ad. Uh and then um here what we
can do with curl which is quite nice. Uh
if you do dashn you can do uh streaming
uh streaming SSE. So this here is
literally nothing magical. This is
literally just you know Jonas
templehello
world. This is literally the curl that
we're doing right here. Um
and um
there I can see the messages coming
through. Very nice. And I can um I can
add another message. And now um
basically uh all all the messages will
show up there. And there's also a um uh
oh, if you do question mark live equals
true. This is inspired by the durable
stream standard, but like ever so
slightly different. But if you do live
equals true, the connection will stay
open and it'll just keep sending you
more events as you as you put them
through. So this is sort of already you
know um like you could say this is an AI
agent if Misha was simultaneously uh
giving responses to my hello world uh
this would already be an agent and then
there's my my AI has told me you can um
if you're going to be doing that a lot
uh you can pipe this uh through set get
just the data elements and then pipe it
through jcq dot and then you get a
little bit nicer formatting. So this is
sort of like uh this is so trivial that
you I actually do spend a lot of time in
curl just curling it. Uh then what can
you do? Um the thing is very tolerant
just in general of of stuff you post to
it and this will become relevant if you
wanted to say send web hooks from random
third parties there. Like my theory is
always that like the LLMs are good
enough. They can basically just consume
raw web hooks from anywhere and and
they'll roughly do the right thing. So
what the what specifically the server
will do is if you send it something that
doesn't um validate like hogwash here it
says there's there's no type property.
So there's not actually a valid event.
Then you can see here what it has
appended is basically an error. But it
because we're event sourcing the error
is also just an event and it just says
here okay um you have an invalid event
appended um event. Oh, another thing uh
that we we will notice is that the type
here uh that our server has created it
starts with https uh events.iterate.com.
You don't have to do that. Uh but that
is something that we like to do because
that literally leads to the
documentation for that event type. And
if it's going to be an opaque string,
like why not make it make it something
uh like that, but uh obviously you can
you can just do you know single words or
two words or whatever. Um but you will
see these URLs and they're just they're
just types. Um then uh what else is
interesting that we can do? I mean this
is kind of boring but you know again if
you're going to do web hooks you have
can put an item potency key in which
just means if you have the same item
potency key twice you don't get um you
don't get the event appended twice. You
can pause a stream. I think in the
interest of time we can skip that. You
can resume a stream. The reason the
pausing is important and is we put this
in even though we literally just made
this a couple days ago is because of the
infinite loops. like it's very very easy
to accidentally put like you know
thousands and thousands of events in a
in an infinite loop in the thing and so
if you put more than 100 events in a
second or something it is just going to
circuit break and then the stream will
be paused until somebody unpauses it. So
basically if you try to um here actually
let's do that because again like for
those of you who haven't seen event
sourcing this might be a bit weird like
how do you pause a stream? Well you
pause a stream by uh oops this is the
wrong one. You pause a stream by
appending an event that uh says you're
you're paused. The the only external
interface to the agent is oh um now it's
complaining. Why is it complaining?
Ah because I think there needs to be a
reason or something maybe.
Uh
yeah,
reason demo. Yeah, there you go. So now
this thing is paused. So now if I um you
know try to send it the hello world
event from earlier, it's just going to
barf and it say no no no more events
allowed. And that is one like that is
one thing that doesn't appear as an
error in the stream because otherwise
you would still get infinite numbers of
error events. Um
uh then I mean there's other weird and
wonderful things you can do. I I don't
even know if we really have to do this
but uh there's like um I have made a
plug-in for this already uh that makes
it so that if I put this JSON
transformer configured event in what
it'll do is it'll just observe certain
events, rewrite them a little bit and
make a new event out of it. But I think
that's a bit advanced so we'll we'll do
it later. Um um it can also do weird
things like it can uh you can schedule
you can schedule things like some agent
SDKs you'll you'll know can do this but
uh here you know if you want like an
like a heartbeat event every five
seconds. Uh oh god now I need to resume
the stream because it's paused. Uh let's
see. stream resumed.
Okay, so now I am just creating uh this
heartbeat event every 5 seconds which
can be quite handy or you can schedule
something for 10 minutes in the future
or at a certain time and again it's just
an event that says do this thing in the
future. Um
um
I think I will skip over these but um
you can cancel the schedule. You can
tell the stream by appending an event to
send your server or some thirdparty
server or your you know your Slack API
endpoint or whatever an event every time
an event gets added. Uh so you can
basically uh subscribe to the stream. Uh
here we're subscribing in our in our
terminal. We're doing a pull
subscription, right? We're doing we're
connecting to uh an HTTP server and
we're getting we're pulling uh pulling
uh we're the HTTP client and they're the
HTTP server and we're getting an SSE
response stream of of streaming events.
But uh it can also do the other way
around where it will push you the stuff
that gets appended or push you a
filtered stream. Um uh which can be
quite handy. Okay. So um let's maybe
stop there because I know also um it
wasn't really clear from the session
description how deeply technical this
was and so let's take any questions on
what is even this thing that we're going
to be using for for the next 45
>> but questions have to be submitted as an
event to the questions stream
>> yeah exactly
>> you have any trouble using
>> that
>> um
does I assume lots of things don't make
sense So please do ask them because I
think this will be extremely like random
and strange so far.
>> What does it do?
>> Oh uh we we're like a we're like a
hacker hobby club at this point to be
quite honest like uh we we are uh we
have not got a launch product. Um
but if we did it would be um I think
based on this architecture. It's like uh
anyway, I'll tell I can talk about it
afterwards.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay.
>> But it's uh Yeah, it's more it's more
homebrew hacker club than than like
commercial enterprise at the minute, but
it'll get there.
>> Yeah.
>> Basic questions
that are on the market right now. Aren't
What's the architecture?
>> It's just um
I think it's just the API like if you um
have you tried to make uh you know like
a like an open code extension or plug-in
or PI extension or claude claude
extension and they all have like an API
surface that is a little bit bigger than
what you would have or what we're going
to have in in a minute. It's not like by
much, right? like okay like maybe the
streaming chunks for partial completions
are a different kind of thing for some
reason rather than just an event of type
I've received you know like five letters
of a streaming response to me that's a
perfectly valid event and and and the
benefit then is that you can uh that can
you I'm kind of like a one abstraction
kind of guy right like this this should
be like a like web standardsbased this
should be there should only be one thing
which is an event and then as you'll see
like the the thing um that was at the
top of this file I think you can build a
super expressive state of the art coding
agent by just implementing uh like a
stream processor that reduces over the
event stream and occasionally an X side
effects. That's that's all it does,
right? Like it just sort of sits there
and says, "Okay, I I'll show you that in
a second." Like it's it's a bit weird.
Um I would say a weird way of
programming.
Um
>> so if I understand correctly, you're
sort of saying take events that you get
generated from an AI models and then
you're basically going to pipe them
through this stream processor.
Is that the idea?
>> The stream processor is or like the
events iterator app is the storage like
you can almost think of it as a database
like one one um you know do you know
convex is like a sort of you know they
they kind of give you the illusion that
they're running Typescript in the
database. You you could almost think of
this this could be like a programmable
stream or something, right? Because
actually one thing that you can also do,
we'll we'll see later once you hack on
your stream processors, you can also
make an event that contains the source
code of your stream processor and then
it'll just run on every event. And and
so like it's basically it is like it is
like the
I think you can experiment with a huge
array of different kinds of agent
harness implementations
uh that can respond to real events on
the internet and make real API requests
without deploying your service or
something like that. All you need is
this sort of um streaming streaming
service that um uh has some of some of
these um things like specifically it
needs to be able to wake up you know
like other other APIs and programs and
so on. I don't know if that Yeah. Um
that does that answer your question at
all or
>> Yeah, I think so.
>> Okay. Shall we try and make uh now a um
like a like a slightly more serious
version of these curls? Um so does
anybody here not know Typescript?
I think so. I think the like one of the
arguments in favor of this architecture
that I also put in that um in that uh in
the in the blurb I think is this is in
principle polyglot right and there is a
uh like in any language there is
actually at events.iterate.comidoccks
iterate.com APIdocs
you have just I mean this is an
exceedingly simple API right um you can
you can make yourself there's a open API
spec you can make yourself a client and
so on but for the purpose of this uh
this um uh workshop here we'll just do a
TypeScript version and we've shipped a
client in a in a npm package already but
I I I just wanted to point out like even
though we're doing everything in
Typescript the whole point is that we
wouldn't have to right but we just have
to do one thing uh for this workshop Um,
okay. So, let's uh let's do do something
pretty simple. Um,
uh, is the AI engineer workshop um,
package uh, now up to date and working?
I think it is, right?
>> I think so. Yeah. Uh, you might need to
pull your repo because there was a
client side type error
>> in the iterate repo.
>> Uh, no, the in the AI engineer workshop.
>> Okay, that's fine.
>> It's in.ts.
>> Yeah, but uh, um, oh, maybe I will
actually use that then. and then I'll be
able to experience uh the same the same
bugs if there are any. Yeah, that's
probably better. Okay. Um Okay. So, uh I
think um if you wanted to just have a
quick start, you can uh you can just
pull uh clone the AI engineer workshop
repo. Um there's already a teeny tiny
example file in there and then we'll
just add a couple more um as we go
along.
>> And the workshop MD has runnable curl as
well.
>> Nice. Yeah.
Um,
if you wanted, you could put a couple
like a couple of the follow on examples
that are in the iterate repo that have
actual processors. Um,
yeah, I can take
I don't know what's going on here.
There we go.
My computer seems to have uh slowed to a
crawl trying to open a cursor window.
This has been unfortunately like a
somewhat regular occurrence recently.
Uh
okay.
Okay.
Or Oh, no. I think this might be what
you mentioned about the internet. I
think it's just struggling because it
can't open a terminal because the my my
terminal tries to connect with the
internet.
Oh, well
then let's do
not the internet,
is it?
There we go. Okay.
Okay. So,
we have here
um we have packaged up an SDK here to
this AI engineer workshop um package
that you should be able to just pmpp
install or you just use uh use this
example here. And then basically uh what
what did we need in our curl, right?
Like we needed a base URL which is just
events.iterate.com. That's where our
server is. uh we can use a path prefix.
Um and um then we can uh run this
function here called create events
client that is from our SDK. And then
this is under the hood. This is
really don't know what's going on with
this terminal. It's very strange.
Okay. Maybe um everything is just
incredibly slow.
>> You want to try mine?
>> Um
>> maybe, but there's nothing actually
hogging the CPU. It's just I I do think
it might be actually the network, but
we'll see. Um
so here
so here you have um
I don't think this has picked up the
anyway. Okay. So this is basically what
we were doing just now right like we we
say okay we're making ourselves a client
uh and then um here there is a function
called stream. This is basically the um
the the the right hand side of the of
the terminal that we had earlier. And
then you say live true and give in the
stream path. And we can say okay if if
uh if the event is not of type ping we
will do nothing. But if the event is of
type ping then we will I mean this is a
completely unnecessary helper down
there. Uh then we can just do client uh
append. I don't understand why the um
the the TypeScript language server isn't
picking up any of the types for me. But
I can't tell if that's just cursor being
weird. Again
>> your own example.
Anyway, um
>> could quickly switch IDs.
>> Yeah, it's fine.
>> It is working for me. Yeah.
>> Okay. Yeah, I think this is
unfortunately like a sort of cursor.
Okay. And then you should be able to uh
just if you have a modern version of
node, you should be able to just run um
or maybe not. Did I make it?
It says invalid TypeScript syntax.
You know what? I'm just gonna I'm just
going to restart cursor. I think that is
worth it.
Is anyone uh able to run this example TS
on their computer? There you go. I am.
Okay.
Um and are you able to send a ping to it
and get a pong out of it? Okay. Very
cool.
Okay.
I Yeah, I wonder if we use use I don't
know if you can see this, but basically
all my commands they have like a several
second delay, which is
>> Yeah, it's looking okay to me. if you
want to just swap laptops. Um
maybe
>> Yeah, no, I know. But it's just Yeah,
it's just my editor doesn't work. And I
also have several non-responsive uh
cursor sort of to I feel like this is a
unfortunately a pattern with cursor
recently.
>> I
>> if you want to swap laptops it does seem
to be working okay from online.
>> I would just give everybody 60 more
seconds to just get get the basic demo
working and then
>> just let me know.
>> Yeah because I think using some you this
is still almost an hour to go. It's not
good to use somebody else's computer.
Maybe I will continue on yours and I'll
just restart my computer. I think that's
a good idea because we can
I also have examples 01 and 02.
>> Oh, really? Oh, brilliant. I
>> think working with something.
>> What's your keyboard layout?
>> Uh, probably the same as yours.
>> One can one can one can hope. Uh, okay.
Entire screen
>> looks the same.
>> Uh, looks pretty good so far.
Um,
what if you got a terminal?
Uh, so
node examples 01 hello world.
Okay, perfect. Yeah. Oh, this works
flawlessly. Uh so um
has everybody got that more or less
working? Because then we can just make
an open AI coding agent now. Um I think
that's all we need.
>> Let's maybe I'll ask um do you have a
speech control in here?
>> Uh yeah, it's control and option. It's
kits one.
>> Yeah. And then
>> that's it. It's recording.
>> Hello. Oh, cool. See that red bar?
>> Um,
>> hey, I would like to make a third
example uh called agent processor and
for that we need to install uh just the
normal OpenAI SDK. Please uh do that and
just make me a new file that looks like
the hello world processor.
Okay. Um
Okay. So,
um
I just got to gather everybody again
after I left you for about uh 10 minutes
here. This is a normal uh pretty normal
spaghetti code TypeScript program,
right? Like basically what we've done
here is we we sort of like doing some
boilerplate work. Um here we want to
subscribe, we we have to make a
subscription. Um, oh my gosh, this
example that you put in there has like
an a board signal and and handles all
kinds of things. And and um anyway, the
the um I think um uh the way I think
about what we're really doing is we're
we're writing a stream processor. And if
you've never done stream processing, uh
this this might be like a bit weird and
people use slightly different names for
for these things, but really um what
we're saying is um there uh exists uh
some kind of world state that we're
interesting in that can be derived from
the events. Uh in this in this example
here that Misha made uh we are uh trying
to count uh the number of times in hello
world event has been encountered in the
stream. And then you can write the
entire logic of your program as uh
effectively a reduce function. This is
this is synchronous and it just um it
just uh looks at all the new events as
they come in and then it updates the
state. That's all it does. So it takes a
state and event and it uh returns the
new state. Or you can just also return
nothing. It'll it'll be fine. It'll just
ignore it. And um and then uh you can
you should not do side effects in this
reduce function. Um, and the reason I've
split the reduce function from from
after append where you should do your
side effects is because uh if you think
about what happens if if your program uh
goes to sleep, right? Like you're uh
you're closing your laptop at the
moment. Everything's running on our
laptops. Uh you know 100 new events go
into the stream. Some of these events
might in the future need to trigger LLM
requests or something like this. And
then you bring you open your computer
again. you start your your program again
and you don't want your program to go
and um make a ton of LLM requests for
all of those 100 events in the past uh
necessarily. Uh instead you wanted to
sort of like catch up all the way and
then decide what to do um with the state
at the end. And so we've made this like
super lightweight um abstraction here of
a processor that basically um gets
hooked up into a processor runtime. Um
and um what it does uh is it splits your
work into reducing events into state and
then if you want to do some side effects
like for example appending um appending
to uh uh you know to the same stream
again you can do this. By the way I
think uh I think you can also do this
which which is like potentially uh
that's pretty interesting. um like uh
you know you you can literally just
append to uh you know like a child path
or you can append to a parent path or or
or whatever um else you want. It's
basically like a meant to be like a file
system. And so if you wanted to build
sub agents on this thing, all you would
do is probably you would just append to
dot slash, you know, Boris and pretend
that Boris is a sub agent and then you
would just subscribe to some special
events that Boris might output like I
have the result and then you would
automatically be woken up again on the
parent when Boris has the result. Um, is
this confirmed, Misha, that this runs?
Like how do you run this? This just
exports the
um like you need you need the runtime,
right?
>> Yes. There is a CLI command that I now
can't remember because my agent's been
running it. Uh,
>> you should be able to do.
>> Did you do all that just now?
>> I did that about a week ago, but you may
have changed.
>> No, no, no. Yeah. Okay. So, okay. Okay.
Um, let's go to our repo. Like I
promised, this is uh
a little bit The these are the um so you
can actually also do this if you go to
iterate AI engineer workshop um here
there are a bunch of examples uh of
files that are um
>> uh workshop two I was going for workshop
>> yeah I also
>> that was meant to be uh meant to be
renamed
um
ah here this is this is this is
basically the snippet we want okay there
is this um there's this thing uh that
you can have. Um so here now we've just
made a processor, right? Like this is
just like a sort of inert thing and then
um there's a thing called a uh pull
subscriptions processor runtime. Um and
all that does is it takes your um it
takes your uh your processor that you
just made and it uh runs it.
Um,
>> I think you probably need to assign it
to a variable because you'll just export
default above.
>> Um, yes.
Okay.
Uh, and here let's just say uh
just see if we can run this.
>> Uh, yes, but unfortunately they need to
be modified uh um in order to uh
um do anything interesting. because I
don't see
>> um
>> yes those ones are those ones are were
added in the last few minutes but uh
using
>> yeah I gave slightly um bad copying
instructions
>> um but I think I think
>> committed
>> uh I think the we're just going to have
to sort of like slowly slowly build it
up in in this repo and then uh push it
once it works here unfortunately Ely.
Um, so here, uh, basically what I've now
done is I've taken this processor and
I've hooked it up, uh, to this runtime
and all the runtime does is it does this
like boiler plate for for consuming the
stream and running the reducer and run
running um, uh, the uh, after append
hook and what we should see is once uh,
you submit hello world into this uh,
into this path here that is just Jonasle
uh, you should get a response there. So
if I go here in the in the UI and I go
to Jonas example and I think I said this
should be event of time hello world. Um
oh no this is up here
if all works. This would be sort of like
the proof point that lets us
it doesn't hello world scene.
Um,
I don't remember if this example relies
on the uh machine username, but if it
does, then that would be mmcal, not
Jonas. Um,
maybe
let's just do this.
Sorry, this is like the worst workshop
because now I'm also on the wrong
computer.
And
it does after
Okay.
Is my computer back up? Yes, but I don't
know your password.
>> Okay. Yeah, I'll I'll do that in a
second. Okay. Um
This example here is not working.
>> Okay. So, I think we have to do plan B,
but we might not actually be able to run
this.
>> Are you getting
>> getting
>> I'm just going to walk through the code
as we would have written it from
scratch.
>> Sorry about that. Um because I think it
it it sort of like illustrates the the
progression of things and maybe if you
>> it's installing dependencies which is is
slow. Uh
>> yeah, but but it's exactly eventually
eventually this will
>> it will be runnable by the walk through.
>> So um in this in this paradigm h as as
we uh we've been using it in our agent
when you want to implement some sort of
feature what you do is you say okay what
is the state I actually need in in order
to do my my my thing in this case we
want to do an LLM request whenever
somebody sends a message and says hi. So
um we have here in our um in our user
interface and you can access this as
well. There is basically like a cheat
code that makes a bit easier to um to
create uh new events of a type called
agent input addit. And this is like
deliberately the simplest possible thing
you can imagine. This is basically just
a string. And so what we're trying to
achieve is that whenever somebody puts
an agent input added event into an event
stream, we want to uh react to that by
making an LLM request. And for
simplicity, we're just going to go in
and do it using the OpenAI SDK. So the
open AI SDK um the way it works is um
you have to
uh at some point uh before you want to
use it you have to make yourself um
here a new open AAI client and then you
can use uh their responses API. So you
have openAI.responses
uh responses.create create and then uh
in order to create it um you need some
information uh specifically you need a
model state uh a string and so
immediately there it's saying okay so
let's just say our state for our LLM
agent it has a model string because that
is one of the things that we will need
when we when we come to actually make an
LLM request and there is nothing but
event sourcing so let's just say okay we
have um we have a model string and that
comes from from um from our state uh and
then you know you could easily imagine
in the future. This was one of the
things that you could have done as an
exercise in in the hackathon is you
could say let's add an event that is
like LLM changed LLM model changed and
you have the teeny tiny oneline reducer
and it just sets the model to be a
different model and then um off you go
you make the next LLM request um with a
different model and the other thing we
need is instructions. Uh this is I think
a bit of a misnomer. So I would call it
system prompt in our state and say okay
the in like the system prompt for our
LLM what is meant to be doing we'll take
that in our state and then you need a
history um a state history and um
and and so we've defined this uh and
normally what you'll do is uh you'll
just put this into into uh like a little
u into like a little TypeScript type if
you're using TypeScript. So here we're
saying this is the state of our agent
right and and in the beginning it's
really simple but in the future you can
very easily imagine how how you quickly
add things to it like state am I
currently compacting or is a tool call
currently in progress or or whatever
else um you might have um and uh the
idea is to create a system in which it
is trivially easy with three four lines
of code to add one of those capabilities
uh to it and then you say okay what's my
initial state um because we're
processing the stream initially there's
no events so we need to know what we're
what we're initially starting with. And
so we're just saying uh this is we're
starting with an empty history and this
system prompt and GPT 5.4.
Um and then the next thing you do once
you've um uh once you've done that is
you need to decide what events do I need
to derive this um to derive this state.
Uh and in this case we will just um
uh create a new event here. Uh a new
we're using zod here for schemas. We're
saying it's an agent input added event
and it just has a string.
Um, and then whenever anything comes
back from OpenAI, because that is like a
fact that has occurred, even if it's
just a teeny tiny fragment of a string
or or something else, we store that in
um in an event. Um, and that's it. Uh,
these are these are the two the two main
event um event types. Um, I don't think
we need any of this stuff here actually.
Basically what happened as is often the
case, I uh I attempted to instruct an
agent to rewrite all of these examples
to uh be simpler to execute just before
and it just um rewrote them quite
significantly. But this is really all
you need. So um and then uh you have to
write your reducer first and the reducer
is basically where you just say okay
when an event is encountered uh how do I
update my um how do I update my uh
state? you say okay when an agent input
addit event um is encountered this here
is using a little like zod helper
library actually one that Misha made
called sche match uh it's just uh it
just gives you basically safety on this
payload here when I have an agent input
addit event then I want my state to be
updated as the current state plus the
history except the history also gets uh
this little uh this little thing here uh
here appended so we're um and and um the
reason we're doing that is because uh
OpenAI's responses API um since we're
making OpenAI processor, we're basically
translating between our view of the
world. We just have this like agent
input and um it's just a string. Uh but
OpenAI wants you to put RO user and and
then put the string in a content field.
So, we're putting that there. Um
and um then the other thing we need to
do um when you use the OpenAI uh
streaming API uh it'll it'll like
basically chuck out tons and tons of
these uh output uh response um events
and uh one of them finally at the very
end will be um of type um
uh
um
Yeah, I think this is a bit hogwash. Um,
>> huh.
>> Yeah. Yeah, exactly. It basically what
we really want here is
um uh
Oh, thank you.
Um, is that actually right?
Um, no.
Um,
let's just
I don't suppose you have managed to get
the
>> I have pushed workshop 2 to the
>> Yeah, but
>> the demo repo, but it's more or less as
is.
streamed like so.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Let Okay. So, let's let's just
like uh sort of like admit defeat on the
thing that I was going to do and just
like try try and show you how how how it
work because we we can get something
like very simple working, right? Because
we have the extremely simple ping pong
processor that that does work. Uh and so
here we can uh we can even uh just
um
let's maybe actually start here.
Oh man, I hit I hit insufficient quote
running my uh
jup.
Yeah, we we do now have the same
examples on the other repo, but it'll
it'll
>> Yeah,
to be honest, I think uh I think we
might have to just admit defeat and we
can just talk about something else or
give you give you the time back just
because the problem is we can't actually
run these things. Uh and I think it
would take me like probably like 10
minutes of actually concentrating to to
get them runnable. Um so maybe we should
uh admit defeat on that. Um, I do wonder
if there's like does,
you know, does it does it sort of make
sense what the what the idea is,
especially with with it being
distributed. So the right that you can
say, okay, like I have my processor over
here and your agent can use it and it
can be on a different server or it can
actually be in a in a dynamic worker. Um
and um
yeah
I I think without showing it it doesn't
really make sense.
So the idea
>> here
I was trying to understand with this
stream processor
>> framework
events are
new.
>> Um
consume the rural materialization side
or part.
So every yeah so so everything that
happens in the system every streaming
chunk everything becomes a becomes an
event in the stream
>> and then you have reducers running in
many different places like uh for for
instance uh you know even this thing
with like is the stream paused or is the
stream not paused the actual
implementation of that is um maybe that
maybe that's actually useful because
this is running in production now uh
like right like there is a circuit
breaker processor and and this is like
how the whole thing is built even inside
the event service and the circuit
breaker processor has an initial state
of paused false and it has pause reason
null and basically then it has a really
really simple reducer um uh that just
checks what are the last 100 time stamps
of events I've seen if the last 100 time
stamps I've seen seen don't go uh you
know don't go more than a second back
then I'm just going to append append an
event so the reducer basically just
accumulates these timestamps and then
the after append function uh here says
okay if I if I have seen too many time
stamps in the last second uh I'm going
to I'm going to throw the circuit
breaker. So, this is like a real
processor that runs inside my uh my um
my uh service. But let me show you
another one. Uh this one here, this UI,
this is also a stream processor. What
does this UI do? The UI takes all of
these events and for some of the events
that it deems like interesting, it
chucks uh it basically it it basically
projects them onto what we call feed
items. So, these things here that have
like a slightly nicer rendering, they
are feed items and they are not the same
as events, but they're derived from
events. So, uh, when you're making UI
for this thing, you're also just
reducing. Um, and because the reducer is
just a synchronous function, right? If
if if you knew, for example, I have I
have this like a PI agent harness
processor and it comes with a whole
bunch of event event types. Um, and it
has a reducer. Um, you can just in your
processor use their reducer. It's
practically free, right? Like you can
just import it and and run it. Uh, and
then you can just sort of like start
building abstractions that rely on their
event types. Um, and so, um, I think
what I'll what I'll what I what I will
commit to doing because this was such a
shitty experience is I will just do do
the whole rundown in video form, uh, on
the on the internet. And that was one of
the things I was going to show like you
can just hook up Pi or Claude or or open
code as well and um, just say, okay,
like they come with a bunch of events
and you can store them in this event
stream and you can react to them or or
build on them. Um,
does that answer the question like where
the reducer runs? Um, um, and and then
like one of the things you can do with
this is you can also actually just
append an event that has some source
code in it and then it runs that
particular processor literally
automatically for you horizontally
scalable. Um,
>> it's just Yeah. Do you have the example
of showing how you do that where you're
appending like a
>> Yeah, I do have that.
>> It's not runnable. I think the is
somewhat.
>> Yeah. Well, actually we can do it here.
Uh yeah, I think I think maybe maybe
that is good. Just like focus instead of
trying to write code, we can focus on
the things that might work. Um so let's
we can create a new stream. By the way,
all streams are created uh you know uh
completely implicitly. So you can just
post to anything under the streams API
and it'll it'll make you a new stream.
And then uh here there's in the UI and
you can also play with this if you want
to just see um there is a there's a
bunch of sort of preset um preset
events. Uh and one of them is here. You
can append an event of type dynamic
worker configured to this thing. And uh
what does it have? It just has a script
in it. And the script is a string. And
inside the string is a reducer uh and an
after append hook. And so this is um
literally a uh like um a stream a stream
processor. It would be funny if this if
this is the thing that works because
this is I was basically I was basically
up most of the night working on this
because this is the most exciting bit.
But it wasn't really like workshop grade
because it was, you know, you get to get
like the first five concepts and then
you're like, by the way, you can deploy
this by just adding an event. Um, uh,
but if I, if I just say ping here, it
says pong, right? That's pretty crazy.
Like I have here a stream uh that knows
nothing about the world and then I have
appended this event here that just has a
little bit of JavaScript in it. And this
little bit of JavaScript uh just makes
it respond with pong whenever it
encounters something with ping. And then
there is actually a a version of this.
This is the thing that actually took
took the night away so to speak is if
you have these processor files that
export a processor that you define with
define processor. You can bundle that
into an event effectively. And this AI
agent I also got running like that. But
of course you don't want to have your
OpenAI API key in there. So that is why
we have this like slightly awkward envir
here where you can put your OpenAI API
key outside of the stream and then um it
will basically when it makes a fetch
request it'll substitute the secret in
in the header. But um yeah, I'll
definitely I'll definitely post a video
of that because that's that's pretty
wild. Like you you can write like the 40
lines of code required for a basic AI
agent and then you can append that to
any stream and then that stream becomes
an AI agent.
I don't know. I'm sort of looking at
like two or three nods but mostly blank
blank stairs. It is very strange. Um but
uh but but I does this does this make
sense what happened here at least
because you can this one you can just
play with like you can just go in the UI
and so uh to some extent uh actually you
can uh you can make increasingly more
complicated processors for your streams.
uh you can just you can just code them
in this input field if you want or uh
you know um the only problem is it
cannot have any dependencies like if you
want to npm packages you have to bundle
it into this string which gets a bit
more complicated but um yeah
>> yeah so this is the other thing like
everything you might have noticed is
everything has a slug it's just like a
URL safe identifier and so the the event
here is actually called dynamic worker
configured because you can override it
and And what also already works with
this event type is you can give
instructions to an AI agent to make
itself
different functionality
just by calling append um with like a
little bit of a different JavaScript. Um
and uh you know you you could you can
quite easily imagine overcoming the
bundling problem for example by just
saying oh there's another event type
which is called like a sort of like
unbundled dynamic worker which just has
a package.json JSON file, a field, and a
script field. And then a different
processor takes it, bundles it, makes
the FAT event that has all of the bundle
source code, and suddenly uh is is
basically like a like IDE. And that's
then where you can you can hack on the
agent harness
without having to really like install
anything or like bring servers into the
mix or or whatever. Um, but sadly was
not able to show it. So, bummer.
Yeah.
>> Uh
>> uh well, this is uh this is JavaScript.
There wouldn't be a typing typing error.
Um uh but it uh if there's any kind of
error, the only thing that can possibly
happen is that you get an event.
>> So there would have to be an error
event. Um,
>> and there's no there are no typing
errors as implemented right now. But you
that's because this is a JavaScript
evaluator, but you could also find a way
to run a TypeScript compilation step on
it first and then you could emit error
saying there was a TypeScript compiler
error. Then you could run it through an
LLM to try and fix it and emit a new
event with the fixed code or do
something else with it.
>> Yeah. Um the idea is that just
everything that happens results in an
event and then you can react to those
events however you see fit.
>> Right.
>> Yes. So in this particular case it's
it's dynamic workers in Cloudflare. So
it it just spins up a small small
dynamic worker. Um, so basically like
the deployment story for a processor
like this is or or like one way to think
about it is uh at when when this was
still working before I ask it to be
refactored and broken, I had um the way
I would do it is I would locally on my
computer I would do the SSE subscription
and run my processor that way and then
once I thought it was cool uh I could
either deploy it just as a web service
on on Cloudflare workers or Versell or
or wherever uh and and just tell uh tell
the um agents the tell the streams to
notify me whenever a new event needs to
be processed or alternatively just use
this dynamic worker thing. Um, and like
there's I don't know if this is going to
work. This is why like at the moment
it's looking more like it's a really
dumb idea I think because it's really
not coming across. But the for example,
you could have a plugin for your agent
uh that runs on another computer,
especially if it was like something like
really important like a prompt injection
protection or something like that. Like
you could say, "Oh, okay. the way that
my agent uses your prompt injection
protection service. It can't really be
through MCP because there's no way to to
kind of like proactively hook into the
agent loop or or at least not at the
minute. But what it could be is it could
say, "Okay, my my agent loop actually
waits for up to like 200 milliseconds
before making any new LLM request uh for
any safety checkers to say and then can
just literally ask your safety checker
over there. I don't care how you
implement it. You could even charge me
for it, right? Um and I just don't yeah
I just don't think that's currently
possible in in any other way. That's why
I think it's quite important that the
stream can reach out to the processors
and say you got to do something you know
you need to process some events now. Um
um there's a there's like a couple other
uh potentially I don't I mean this might
Yeah.
>> The idea one of the ideas you shared is
my agent might use just in time services
other agents are offering.
>> Yeah.
>> Then he might be charged with it.
>> Yeah. Well, I mean like probably in
initially the human would be charged of
it, but but this is just like there's no
way like let's say okay so cloud code if
I want to make a cloud code plugin um if
if I wanted to make that into a business
think think about how you would have to
do that at the moment it and you need to
give some sort of instructions uh or or
something to to uh to claude code either
to proactively call your MCP tools or or
something of that nature or call maybe
some CLI tool that was previously
authenticated where you did like CLI log
to you know like prompt injectionp
protector.com and then somehow it works
where whereas um uh really I think you
can just plug into the into the agent
stream like into the event stream
directly like the the interface is just
somebody somebody notices that claude is
about to do something and chucks some
more events in and and like they kind of
all work that way but not quite like
it's uh it's sort of like you have to
squint a lot to to see that that's what
it all compiles down to. Um um another
thing maybe worth pointing out for some
of you that have tried to like tried to
make open code or or or PI plugins or
whatever is there's no before hook. This
is very very important. There's no like
um there is actually in the back end
like our built-in processes. The only
difference to our processes and your
processes is that we can actually stop
events from ever being appended. For
example
by a third party. So there's sort of
like certain things that are just um
that that need to happen before an event
goes in the stream. But um broadly
speaking, I'm very against before hooks.
Like I think there were some instances
in in Open Claw, for example, some
massive performance regressions and and
cost increases where you know you can
you can break uh um you can break
context caching quite easily with before
hooks. You can massively destroy
performance. like it's just way better
to think of the whole system as as being
eventually consistent and uh you know um
doing all these distributed systems
things like saying okay we're going to
wait for up to 200 milliseconds for
somebody to say I've got a little bit of
information for you but then we're
actually going to make the LLM request
whether you come in with information or
not because this is needs to be system
so if you think for example about rag
pipelines and things like that you can
easily have a little processor that says
I have like a indexed version of the
notion knowledge base or something and
I'm just going to sit here and try to
squeeze in a little bit of extra context
if I think it's relevant, but if I don't
get there in time, it's like totally
chill. The whole thing still works. It's
not like I' I've kind of delayed the um
the agent or something. Um
yeah,
>> you mean I mean the the the streaming
database
like I don't know I I I think um I think
this could work on almost anything that
is like durable stream shaped. So this
was just for the purposes of this um
exercise. Uh I do think like there is
potentially an interesting scenario
where uh like where a like
it's not even really like it's a
combination of a Q and a pub subsystem
and and like a streaming database and uh
that can also run code for you. But but
that that sort of thing is an
interesting infrastructure primitive
that uh maybe somebody could make. Um I
do think that uh yeah but in in
principle like I I don't know if you
don't know about it yet you can read up
on this durable streams uh API
specification that somebody came out
with. We don't follow it exactly but uh
close enough and it's it's basically
like a like a very common old idea like
um the thing that is more new is that it
would be like you would also have push
subscriptions out of it but there are
some things that do is there's a thing
called n like jetreamenat or something
uh that that does it um yeah
>> are you talking about the electric core
>> yeah exactly they they have durable
streams
And like a durable stream is just like
an appendon event log with with offset
tracking and and the the the you know
they want the client to track the last
consumed offset. That's also how say
Kafka works or something like that. But
you can also do it the other way around
and have the server track the offsets
and those are more normally like there's
Google Cloud and AWS they have these pub
subsystems where they say oh we'll just
like give you the next event and we'll
keep track of of the offset for you.
>> Um
Yeah.
>> And then anyone could essentially pass a
stream that would go to my generically.
>> Oh, I mean you would need to have
authentication on it, right? Right. Like
this this entire thing would never uh
like right. like this. Uh I was thinking
like it might be fun to just say there's
a
>> do that yet basically.
>> Yeah, exactly. It might be fun to just
say there's a public namespace and it
just gets cleared every hour or
something, right? Because it is kind of
nice that anybody anywhere on the
internet can just curl a thing or like
copy and paste a curl from somewhere and
and suddenly have like a flavor of
agent. I do think that's quite
interesting, but it just needs to be
deleted every like quite aggressively.
Um yeah, but but I think I think that's
more or less a solved problem. It's like
a bit gnarly, but basically the way I am
envision it you would do it um if you
did this properly is on each event you
basically have like client provenence
information. We say like who was this
like what were they able to do like how
how sure are we that these people you
know the HTTP client or the the stream
client was actually entitled to do this
operation.
And and again, you can model all of that
as events, right? Like you can you would
just have an event that is like make
this stream public and until you make
that event, it can only be uh written to
by whoever created it or something.
Um,
right. I might ask uh um Sean if we can
instead of this video do a video we'll
record a little bit later today um that
shows it more nicely because I do think
it's worth showing.
>> Just a little bit too short short
notice.
Shall we just wrap it then? If uh I I
don't mean to keep you all of your uh
like 10 minute late longer break or if
anybody wants to chat.